[Música]
[Aplausos]
porque estamos aquí
como llegamos hasta aquí para que
existimos
qué es la vida
que hay aquí adentro existe algo más que
un simple cuerpo cuando te mueres que
apagan la luz y a
y es que verán que existen estas
preguntas
hace que nuestra presencia sea relevante
porque hasta donde sabemos somos la
única especie que se lo pregunta en este
planeta
acaso fuimos creados para
encontrar estas respuestas
no lo sabemos
y después de muchos milenios de esfuerzo
arduo de generación y generación no las
tenemos
todavía salvo claro está las que nos
proveen las religiones y la fe que son
de carácter espiritual pero las
respuestas que vienen de la razón
la verdad es que hemos encontrado muchas
muchísimas otras respuestas pero las
fundamentales todavía no
y la verdad es que es el mejor de los
escenarios
porque es mejor tener
respuestas por encontrar
que tener respuestas
y mientras todo esto sucede yo el día de
hoy les quiero hablar de algo que si
sabemos
existir
es regalar a todos
yo sé
partamos del hecho de que para que
puedas disfrutar todo esto necesitas
físicamente existir
para que puedas ver o leer roban ar
kuchar tocar
para que puedas abrazar y besar
necesitas un cuerpo y ese cuerpo
que está hecho de átomos pero lo más
interesante es que este cuerpo
intercambia átomos con todo lo que le
rodea de manera constante y eso es muy
importante
y pensamos en esta piedra por ejemplo
pues evidentemente tiene una cierta
organización sus átomos están
organizados de cierta manera hay una
cierta complejidad hombre no es una
complejidad muy interesante porque no
hace mucho pero si la ponemos en un río
y regresamos algunos meses después
veremos que su forma ha cambiado
y lo habremos logrado porque el agua que
corre a su alrededor habría forzado el
intercambio de átomos
si pensamos por ejemplo en
bacteria que es esta en particular es
una de las formas de vida más simples
y la observamos por un tiempo veremos
que constantemente ingiere alimento del
entorno y también se deshace de lo que
necesita
y en ese proceso va creciendo y después
de más o menos 20 minutos
por un proceso que se llama mitosis se
parte la mitad
ética
aquí evidentemente hay una interacción
mucho más grande y veloz que la de la
piedra
consideremos algo con lo que todos hemos
jugado tierra todos lo hemos tenido
las manos todos hemos sentido los grumos
entre los dedos y si nos ponemos a
pensar y pues la verdad es que hay
miles de sustancias y depende del tipo
de suelo y demás pero se pueden hacer
algunas agrupaciones
para entender mejor básicamente la mitad
es agua y aire
que están ahí atrapados entre los bombos
y hay un 45 por ciento que son minerales
y hay un 5% que es materia orgánica
y si tomamos únicamente
la materia orgánica y la analizamos más
a detalle veremos que 10 por ciento son
raíces 10 por ciento son lombrices y
otros seres vivientes y 80 por ciento es
humus que no es otra cosa más que restos
de seres vivos
20 vida 80%
pasada
lo cual hace sentido porque
todo lo que vive eventualmente muere
y terminé en el piso para después
descomponerse los gusanos y los algas y
bacterias tienen la
o con rosa tarea pero muy fundamental
de comerse a todos los muertos del
planeta llámese
hojas tallos insectos animales nosotros
todos
pues te mueres los gusanos te comen
alguien más se los come a ellos y en
este entorno
los desechos de uno son el alimento de
otros y aquí hay toda una muy compleja
red biológica una intrincada cadena de
digestiones sucesivas
pero visto desde otro ángulo
es un proceso de construcción y otro de
reconstrucción al mismo tiempo
porque una lombriz es como una hoja
una
gallina se come a la lombriz
y al mismo tiempo en ese entorno hay una
zanahoria que está tomando nutrientes
del suelo para crecer y esos nutrientes
son desechos de hongos sanz algas
bacterias
y también de la lombriz
de la gallina
y eventualmente la gallina y la
zanahoria terminan en un caldo que
en su embarazo
y en ese fantástico viaje átomos
lombriz hoja gallina
y todo lo que comieron
entonces la cascada de preguntas es
inevitable cuántos seres están
involucrados en que yo existe a quienes
fueron como vivieron como murieron tengo
en mi átomos que fueron de otras
personas también
quienes me regalaron todos estos átomos
no sabemos las respuestas a las
preguntas fundamentales
lo que sí sabemos es que
existir es un regalo atómico ya mí eso
me parece
la verdad es que
ese 5% más que
además que digestión más que recicladora
de átomos
es un vínculo entre vidas es una
conexión entre pasado y futuro es una
enorme colección de
historias
después de que nace
tienes que alimentarte de saciar tu sed
respirar
lo cual significa a tus
y hacen los cálculos se darán cuenta
de que el adulto promedio entre
alimento agua y aire diariamente
intercambia varios kilogramos de materia
con
lo que le rodea
y de hecho ese intercambio sucede muchas
veces sin darnos cuenta
cuando se vayan hoy de aquí se van a
llevar algunas moléculas de agua del
cabello de los demás
y eso es solo el agua que se evapora del
pelo
habría que contar todo lo que respiraron
todo lo que tocaron y un larguísimo
etcétera cuando se vayan de aquí hoy se
van a llevar algo de los demás
por el hecho de haber estado por el
hecho de ser
por existir
y eso distingue a la vida de los demás
cantidad y la velocidad a la que nos
regalamos
y la verdad es que yo no tengo control
sobre
los ocho puntos 0 2 por 10 a la 30
átomos
que me hacen yo de alguna manera se
organizan para sergio y constantemente
están cambiando y sigo siendo yo
trillones y trillones llegan a mí todos
los días y otros tantos me dejan
sigo siendo yo
y la verdad es que los átomos
lo hacen por razones muy egoístas ellos
no piensan no les importa nada no les
importa esto ni les importa yo
ellos desde hace miles de millones de
años han ido pasando de cosa en cosa de
ser en ser
y no les importa
y no les importa ser yo
y sin embargo que estén aquí hoy
es algo que agradezco profundamente no a
ellos
sin a los seres
que me lo regalan a cada instante
para existir necesito un constante
regalo
de átomos y también debo regalar la
misma cantidad
y lo único a lo que puedo aspirar con
humildad
es
o usarlos para hacer el bien
y enviarlos limpiecitos
con un moño de regalo
a los que me rodean
y por eso digo que existir es regalar a
todos
[Aplausos]
[Música]